all right sammy
sammy where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
uh peoria illinois oh my god really
yeah
not really it's just [ __ ] i know
where peoria is oh do you my ex-wife is
from peoria
oh
tell me about your childhood
childhood i mean yeah it was crazy i
mean
immediately
i wasn't even part of the family because
i was taken away my mom was a
barefoot gutter punk in the streets of
new orleans when she got pregnant so
living in a car so i didn't get back
into the family till i was like three
tell me about your parents
oh well
mom and dad were never together i mean
they had sex and she got pregnant but
she was 14 and he was 19 so
um she went back to illinois
from new orleans and he went back to
houston
so there wasn't really a fan i didn't
even meet dad till i was 14.
huh who raised you
um
grandma and the sister i mean mom had me
for a few years but not long
um
kind of raised myself i guess
uh
how far did you go to school
uh i dropped out in 11th grade with a
4.0 i mean i've always had incredibly
good grades i was
pretty smart kid but um life just i was
bouncing back and forth between group
homes and i said [ __ ] it i'm gonna go to
new orleans you know i'm just gonna take
off so and you went to new orleans at
what age
was it 15 or 60 16 i think 16 right
before i turned 17 i think early in your
childhood was there ever any abuse you
know in the foster system anything like
that um
there was some weird [ __ ] but nothing
like no sexual or
no no physical abuse towards me but i
mean yeah
i saw some [ __ ] and i mean i had people
threaten me like
foster parents like
you know screaming at me in my face but
i mean kids are kids they shouldn't be
treated like that
but
nothing i seen should happen to other
kids though
there was one kid he was schizophrenic
and
their kids would pick on him and tease
him and he'd be like hallucinating [ __ ]
it was mean
but
yeah
the system's [ __ ]
but
i did get finally when i was 14 i got
put into an independent living program
which
they changed some laws in the state of
illinois to make this happen because at
the time he had to be 16
but i had been like
in limbo
in what they called shelter care there
for a long time so
it was good for me because i was kind of
a grown-up kid anyway so i was able to
function because you know you got to get
a job and
pay bills and do chores blah blah blah
but a lot of 14 year old kids that would
come in there after they couldn't handle
it didn't even know how to get a job
um
but yeah just uh things i finally got
out and went and moved it i got the
state just instead of paying
you know a group home or foster parent
or something like that i got them to pay
me and then i would pay my best friend's
parents to rent a room downstairs and
when i was 15 and
um
there was some
their daughter was skipping school and
they blamed me for it and
it really didn't have anything to do
with me at all but whatever they kicked
me out so that's why i said go to new
orleans and went down there
got a job on bourbon street i was
the hand grenade man because i couldn't
legally work in the bar so i was the
mascot outside and i would dance around
and get pictures taken and [ __ ] like
that
um
but by the time i was
17 i
was bartending
they you know they let me in anyway i've
got to be 18 there but
um
it was fun that was a fun time in my
life i made a lot of money i lived and
worked on bourbon street i barely left
bourbon street my first apartment was
above a world famous strip club
um
but then that came to an end the the
owners of the bar i worked for were they
were drunks and they would hang out at
their own bar and
just one night you know they [ __ ]
let some girl and then i knew it was old
enough
she was pregnant she just wants to come
in and get a water and go pee
she does it all the time i checked her
writing before i didn't check it that
night fire
so i might like when turned in there and
then i went to california
and learned how to do flooring which god
that sucks
did flooring for like 17 years
um
you've been in california ever since
no i went back
we moved the company to houston for a
while
and the money was good there but i hate
houston it's just
miserable
you know giant cockroaches and giant
rats and crime and humidity and it's
like new orleans it's almost same but
except for no bourbon street
um
so i was only there like seven months
and then i went
and stayed with my mom in iowa for a
little while
got married up there
horrible [ __ ] mistake
um that didn't last
very long at all
but uh
and then i went to
stay with some friends because my wife
she left cleaned out the house took
everything and well one day while i was
at work
and so i went to stay with a friend of
pennsylvania
i finally got a call from my uncle hey
come out to california came out here
for like two months and then i went down
to mexico live down there for like four
years
and you've been trans for how long
um i mean you know like everybody's
doing stuff
like you know i always liked
wearing the clothes and stuff but i
never did it in public until
about a year and a half ago i guess
which i regret i wish i would have done
it a lot sooner really
oh yeah i mean are you happier now
well yeah yeah i feel more like me i
don't feel so subconscious and i know
that sounds weird because i mean at
first you know you kind of are just
because
you know i lived in mexico at the time
when i did it and so like people down
there were like way behind the times on
that [ __ ] you know i mean even though
they actually had like
gay laws
in their favor way before we did here
yeah that was all political for money
[ __ ] so it's not really true they don't
[ __ ] really accept it
so it was hard it's kind of a relief
being here i don't catch so much [ __ ] in
hollywood you know what i mean
people are judgmental pricks everywhere
but these are rough on the streets
um
you know what i can handle anything
i i mean i
it was rough at first um when i was in
mexico i
i did uh you know buy sell and trade
goods at the swap meets and stuff and i
continued to do that when i got here
because it's just what i knew
and at first people were stealing my
[ __ ] all the time and
so but then i i've got some fence panels
i built a big cage
that i [ __ ] anchored to the ground
you know to the concrete and the chains
locked it up and nobody steals my [ __ ]
anymore so i do okay i mean i do make a
little money
not as much as i'd like but
you know i'm safe too you know i i can i
don't really feel homeless a lot of
times except for i don't have a shower
that part sucks if i had a bathroom i
could live in my cage for the rest of my
life i really could i'm pretty simple
um but you know i got a nice bed and
it's a little area to hang out and got
my half of it for my work and dear
friends
does anybody are there friends still
i mean i think acquaintance is closer to
the
definition of friends now
it doesn't seem like
no my best friend
sally
she was my dog
um i got deported from mexico that's how
i ended up here on the streets
um and they [ __ ]
[Music]
the [ __ ] cops murdered my dog
they're demons
and they did it for no reason to hurt me
it was a battle down there you know i
was down there making money and i did it
in a fashion that made a lot of people
happy but the police they always want
your money
and
they took and took a touch from me so
much and finally i
put my foot down you know i read the
written laws of mexico and i this is the
first time my whole life i was always
told
you're too smart for your own good i
never understood it didn't make any
[ __ ] sense to me whatsoever how can
you be too smart for your own but it
doesn't make any sense right well i
figured it out down there you know what
i mean because i was smart and i
learned my flaws and
and invoke my rights and
they just they showed me with
[ __ ] mexico we do whatever we
want
bye
you know i mean so then i'm like
standing in san ysidro with nothing you
know and my dog just gone
and yeah i don't know i i
that was a real weird situation too i
was only there for like
maybe a week and a half or something
finally i went to the train station and
asked some guy if he'd buy me a ticket
to la figure i've never been here before
so
better no better time to check it out
and then i didn't know where i was going
got on train i asked
you know
what should i do when i get off the
train or they're like you know go to get
on the
the metro or whatever and i get on the
mentor and i ask cops where should i go
and they're like highland and hollywood
okay so that's where i went and that's
where i stay most of the time i don't
really
venture too far
how do you get treated on the streets as
a trans
the transfer isn't that bad i mean it's
the homeless that [ __ ] people treat
you like [ __ ] for the most and i mean
that's that shit's ridiculous
the home or whatever you want to call
them they need educated you know what i
mean like
they they don't
the biggest problem really i think is is
they don't understand
our situations at all
they automatically assume everybody's on
drugs and that's how we got there and
that's how we're gonna stay there and
and and we're dirty and
i don't know
you know they don't understand when when
when the guys hold up besides says i'm
starving
they don't know what that feeling is
when they say i'm starving it's they
just ate four hours ago i mean
they're probably eating something right
then when they're saying it
are drugs a part of your life
are drugs a part of your life they are
they are um
you know i i
i'm not an all day or anything like that
i don't sit around get high i mean i i
do my thing
i handle my business
and i get high at night because at night
when i and when i'm done with everything
and i got nothing to do that's when
the worst starts happening that's when i
start thinking
and i'm crying and you know what i'm
just asking how i forget about it
and
i mean it
didn't really start that way it started
more of like
um
just trying to be up protect my [ __ ] i
was like people are stealing from me
while i sleep and [ __ ] like that you
know but
yeah yeah
it's uh especially on crystal meth is
that your drug yeah yeah yeah you pass
out for days right pass out for days do
you sleep
no i mean
no not much i figure i'll sleep when i'm
dead
let's see
you basically don't sleep
i sleep a couple hours every day but oh
i said but you usually i mean i have
every once in a while i might sleep like
14 hours or something that's what i'm
talking about but that's pretty i mean
that's like maybe twice a month or
something that's what i'm talking about
that's a great opportunity to get robbed
yeah well i'm in my cage so
oh i'm okay now yeah i mean i'm locked
down you're in a cage seriously it's it
uh could like the fence panels six by
twelves that they put around
construction sites i got a bunch of them
and chained and locked them together and
anchored into the concrete yeah
and then my door it's a big you know a
chain and i anchored a bolt to the see
you're safe to the ground and
lock it down and yeah nobody's getting
in there i mean they could they cut the
fence and stuff but nobody does that the
average person isn't walking around with
tools for that do you have children no
thank god i wouldn't bring anybody into
this [ __ ] world
or i don't want to anyway
it's not what we
it's not what you when you're growing up
it's just the world is not what you
think it's going to be
and especially when you end up in a
situation like this where you're
homeless and people just dog on you
i mean
i mean i understand too like people here
are [ __ ] bombarded with homeless too
you know like where i grew up i mean
there was like a homeless guy you know
so like people felt sorry for him and
helped him and
i mean nobody ever bought him a house or
anything but
not that i think they should have but
it was different you know
now it's like
you know i get it i tell people like
when somebody they ask me for money all
the time i'm like [ __ ] broken
homeless too dude but like why don't you
you know
that's annoying don't ask me for like
don't ask anybody for money i just don't
know you know offer something that's why
i sell [ __ ] you know i mean
i can make my money without pestering
people
they don't like it i leave them alone
you know
some of these guys are that's all they
do is just stand outside at 7-eleven and
i'm like can you do anything else guys
come on now
what was it that's the best time of your
life
best time in my life
before i ever knew anything about money
i mean
money's biggest [ __ ] problem we have
it's always every problem we have in the
world
it's absolutely evil
you know
there's no reason people should have
i mean of course in just in
in numbers people are going to have more
than somebody else but i mean come on
out i mean what do you even do when you
have a billion dollars what's so what's
so great like i don't understand it at
all
i mean are you like
you need a blow job the entire second of
every day or something like i mean i
just don't understand like what you even
do with that kind of money and what
makes it so much better and why wouldn't
my biggest problem if i had that much
money would be trying not to give it all
away
you know i'd be wanting to [ __ ] feed
everybody i mean
the world people serving in the world is
just disgusting to me
especially in our own country but in the
whole world too i mean we waste enough
food in this [ __ ] country every day
to feed them all for five years
and that's so it's ridiculous but
that's what keeps our dollars strong
right i mean at 61 they abolished
gold did a petrol dollar for a few years
or whatever and since then there's
nothing backing him but we print it like
a [ __ ] because we control who's
hungry
you know we make 90 of the world's food
we [ __ ] sell rice to china now
i mean
we control who's hungry so yes sir
dollars worth whatever can i have my
[ __ ] rice now
that's how i feel about it anyway i
don't know if that's true but it feels
like it probably is because otherwise i
don't see how our dollar i mean there's
every every day what is it like 1700
millionaires become
in this country it's like
how is there that much money that
doesn't make any sense they're just
printing it it's just coming out
why don't they just give us all
something
you know maybe
everybody should get like one time in
their life like use a million dollars
don't [ __ ] it up
if you [ __ ] it up who cares it all goes
back to the rich anyway the poor people
spend their money nothing rich the rich
spend their interest
you know
how do you support yourself how do you
make money the swap meets and selling
stuff online which i hate that too but
you know you're not doing sex working
like that no no never stole my body i
give this [ __ ] away for free
that's a joke um but no i don't sell
i've never
never done that yeah would you describe
yourself as happy
i mean people say i always have a smile
i try to be
you know you seem to be i try to
value the things
that are really
valuable
and important and
if if i was concerned about money all
the time i would absolutely be depressed
because
i don't know i mean i probably somewhere
in me have the potential to make a bunch
of it but
even if i did i'm really bad with it i
spend my money doesn't matter how much
money i make every day i wake up broke
you know
i'd like to shop
i like to eat
and i don't know if i'm going to be
around tomorrow anyway so
how old are you i'll be 39 i'll take
patty's day 39.
if you had your life to live all over
again would you have done anything
differently
i'm going to start with that one where
would that be the starting point for
doing it all differently
um
yeah i mean i guess uh
there was a girl named pearl
beautiful
soul beautiful body i mean everything
about her was great
um i met her in mammoth lakes california
lived there for like six years
and that was the biggest town she'd ever
lived in in her life
um she was american indian just
i wish i would have bettered her i was a
complete prick i mean a snowboard 150
days a year i was selling a bunch of
weed i just thought i was king of the
world back then and i was a dick to
everybody
should have married that girl she'd have
been good for me
that would have been a good start um
before that though
i try not to really have any regrets you
know everything i've done and experience
it's all part of who i am and what i am
and i don't feel like i'm a shitty
person or anything so
i mean i've got things like that i feel
bad for but we all make mistakes that's
human
i have to make mistakes as long as you
learn from them yeah then it's okay you
know what i mean but if you start keep
doing it you know you're dumb ass at
least that's what i was taught my uncle
taught me a lot when i came to
california at 18 and learned a family
business my uncle was kind of like the
dad to me and
and he taught me a lot about life and
you know at first i thought he was a
complete prick
but now that i'm older it's like yeah
i'm glad he was around
glad i learned from him
he's in mexico he's got
tons of kids down there and
three different women
are your parents still alive
yeah i think so i'm pretty sure i don't
really talk to him when's the last time
you spoke to your parents
[Music]
dad i spoke to since i've been here but
he was a douche bag and i just [ __ ] i
i blocked him from facebook and told him
leave me alone
dad's been a punk band since he was a
kid and
it's just that's how he is he's just a
punk you know i mean
he will always be younger than me
um
mom
she was [ __ ] up growing up and real
abusive i wasn't with her very much but
she's changed her life i mean she
she's
she went from working on bourbon street
to
moved to egypt for like eight years
became a muslim and then came back here
and was a
mormon for forever and then i don't know
what she's doing now she's somewhere
she's either here in california or in
arizona i think
but i don't know covet hit
um i hadn't talked to mom in like
i don't know a year and a half or
something i called her up
oh my god so glad to hear from you
um it's time
you know things
weren't that great economically and
i told her what was going on and i was
really homeless but i was like living in
like basically somebody's closet down in
mexico and so she's like oh let me send
you a thousand dollars and then you know
over a few months see
and she helped me buy trucks my truck
got stolen down there
give me like six grand in six months or
something like that and then covet hit
and like she's just substitute teachers
she had no work they shut down the
schools and she just blamed me for all
her financial problems now and
stopped speaking to me
but i don't really even care anymore you
know what there's they've been shitty
parents my whole life i don't need them
anyway
i did even when they were there they
[ __ ] weren't useless
well dad was never there but
you know mom i mean i can be
i remember being like
seven or eight years old she'd just
disappear for two or three days at a
time so
you know
but i took care of myself i went to
school every day
you graduated high school i didn't
graduate um i left i went to new orleans
but uh i did get my ged finally when i
was like 30
which
was a cake walk
um
never really needed i only had one job
that even asked me if i
graduated high school um
you know was doing flooring and stuff i
mean we just worked for ourselves and
then i've been doing what i do here now
for
three or three and a half years or
something like that almost four i don't
know
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
it doesn't matter how much money you
make it's
what's important is how much you save
because when [ __ ] hits the fan
as much as i hate money you gotta have
some you know because the the landlord
and the grocery store they don't accept
barter and
you know skills for payment
um
i don't know if that's the most
important thing are you saving money
[ __ ] no i might die tomorrow who knows i
mean i don't care about saving money
but
you know it's too late for that i mean
that's not engraved to me
if i had it if i could go back and have
that engraved into me as a young kid
that would be great because if i [ __ ]
if i would have saved
ten percent
like tied into the church or something
of everything i've ever made i'd be fine
right now you know i have made money in
my life
i just always spend it
it goes fast
um and then you know being homeless i'll
tell you what it's expensive to be
homeless
you know i
at first i didn't want like any help at
all like i get ebt now you know to help
with food
and at first i like no i don't need any
[ __ ] mom had us on that [ __ ] as a kid i
didn't want a part of my life
and uh
when you're doing that that can be
really expensive because everything you
eat is like from a restaurant or the gas
station and you know you can't save
anything you don't have a fridge
um
and and when people are stealing your
[ __ ] too oh my god you gotta replace
everything i've never i was going about
crazy like every couple weeks i'm like
at the store buying the same [ __ ]
makeups and or whatever it is that i
needed to replace because
somebody stole my bag again
and makeup is expensive
and i don't really like to steal
i mean i can't say i'm perfect and
haven't but
i try to keep it as minimal as possible
there's plenty of stuff out there for me
to obtain i mean hollywood people just
leave the craziest [ __ ] just laying
around and i can make money off that and
buy what i need
but the economy is really bad right now
though so people aren't buying like they
used to and
you know i made killer money in mexico
actually really good money down there
swap meets
yeah um i
at the when i first went down there i
didn't work do anything for money the
first year i had a little bit of an
income coming in um
and just observing i'm like i lived in
this little gringo community called san
miguel
and i just noticed how wasteful these
people were so i started
talking to them and going to other
communities and saying you know throw
that away call me i come in my truck i
get it donate it
to me and then i sell it for dirt cheap
because 100 profit
people everybody's happy you know what i
mean
so that worked out really good i mean
you feel like you were loved in your
childhood
oh no
[Music]
i don't know i feel like
i feel like if i had children and i
loved them i would love them forever
and
they they wouldn't be
on the streets i mean i just can't see
how anybody loves me you know what i
mean like what the [ __ ] am i doing out
here i got
no friends no family
they all said i feel like you were ever
left i i don't know i mean
only because they were supposed to
because i was a kid they're like oh
there's my grandkid or uh that's my kid
i gotta love him right i don't know i
mean
in hindsight now it's like i don't know
mom i mean how you [ __ ] i mean mom
would pick up anything
hockey stick fish bowl
just push my head through the wall
whatever it took to [ __ ]
hit me or hurt me so i mean i
i think
yeah
that's a [ __ ] thing to teach a kid
too because that teaches them you can
beat somebody up and love them at the
same time
which is probably why i was aggressive
in my twenties you know and
i wasn't really that good to a couple
girls
because i thought i could love them and
beat them too i guess i don't know i
didn't
love i don't
know people love family because they
have to
uh
romantic love that shit's [ __ ]
that loves a hard dick
once that goes away we're all just about
ourselves everybody's about themselves
these days i hate that
i like to say that i have so much love
in my heart that it makes me [ __ ]
hate everybody
because we're so shitty to each other
and ourselves and our planet
i wish i could spill the love and
give it and teach people and
can't
everybody's too concerned about how fat
their wallet is most people out here
would steal from their own mother if
they thought it was going to fatten
their wallet just a tad bit
um
people suck coronavirus needs to do a
better job or something we need
something there's too many people in the
[ __ ] world
all right all right sam thank you so
much for sharing your story yeah yeah i
wish i could go longer thank you very
much i hope that was okay it was great
you